on this week's show should I rent or buy
where I live in the news new website
helping renters faked or orc landlords
and we're going to be answering all your
property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham and welcome
to the property investors podcast this
is where she gonna be talking we
answered a question about this the other
day and we were like we you know it's
such a good topic that we could explore
and hopefully give people a lot a lot of
information in and and also I do think
it depends a little bit on what type of
house you want to live in yeah there's a
bit more to it we can go into but it's a
great topic because so many people so
people are confused by this they just
totally don't understand why on earth
with a property investor ya not own the
house that they live in yeah it's
serious that every event I've been since
I've had at least five people come up to
me and see they can't get the head round
why you would not buy your doesn't make
sense your property in by you'd rent it
so we're gonna talk about that which is
pretty cool and by the end of the show
you will know whether or not you should
buy or if you should read your own house
yep so yeah it's gonna be a good show
how have you been this week I've been
really good we just come off the back of
three two crash courses so we has crash
course last week and straight again this
week we've got a deal friend
extravaganza this week so Allah - a
couple of days of in the office and then
back on it but yeah it was really good
crash course was a phenomenal a weekend
it was in Birmingham it was in
Birmingham city centre I to be fair I
didn't go on I guess I don't it was just
me and Samuel this one and but yeah it
was very good a really really good crowd
really good crowd they were very very
energetic they played fallout and they
were doing lots of good stuff nice man
no it's a really nice room yeah it was
all good and what have you done anything
interesting in your personal life got a
puncture on my car
no no then brand-new Porsche got a
puncture it keeps going down and so I
need to take that into the garden to
back the Porsche Porsche it's not
Porsche Porsche back to Porsche tomorrow
and they're going to them sort that out
for me and but that's really about it
so you just driven around getting
punches yeah sounds like you've had a
fantastic where because of so and we're
in London now I don't I'm not using the
car as much as I was so it stays in the
car park getting punctures well it was
in the car park for like four days not
be moved cuz I ain't my department I've
got an underground car park so it stays
in there I'm not being moved and I went
back and it's got a pretty flat tire and
I'm a great fixer anyway we'll get that
sorted but you know it's been pretty
pretty cool on that one but yourself so
I went to Kew Gardens nice very very
nearly moved to Q Oh
and then I went and then I went round it
a bit yeah and I thought you know what I
made such the right decision Movida
beckons field oh it was just better okay
God's very nice but do you know where
else is nice in London Regents Park
right if you go into Regents Park
there's a inside there's like our whole
area of just flowers and just like him
like really nice flowers I went that's
really really nice really good never
expect that as well what I mean is it's
like there's walkways and more years
love in middle of London it is and it's
not touristy though is it when I were
it's just like sort of local people and
it's very very chill where our office is
like a stone's throw it's on Regis palm
just great so yeah awesome and one
really really good week right let's get
delving into this then so do you
should you buy or should you read first
all this have a look at the advantages
for for buy quit buying so most people I
mean I found this when I was when I was
looking for a house here and I was
always looking at letting agents and I
would say to them oh they say well what
is it you do yeah I run a training
business mm-hmm that primarily teaches
people to invest in property and that
they would look at me like
and you're looking to rent yeah yeah
look into rent and they're confused so
well first of all why would people
assume or don't even need to say this
why would people assume there's a
property investor you should buy where
you lived
I don't know I don't know why they do
that I don't know why but it is it's a
common thing I get it a lot I get it
every event I get many people mesh to me
why do we rent not owned the reality is
is because your home is not generally
seen as an investment is probably
overall in the sense of you will benefit
from cap appreciation things that but if
on the face of it though it sounds
stupid because you could over rent a
house yeah and therefore you're paying
dead money to a landlord who's making
money from or if you could like you're
almost the perfect tenant for yourself
but good so or you can just buy it and
then you're you're gaining capital
appreciation so why would why would
someone who makes their living from
ruining houses not own their own house
it's crazy okay so I personally would
say look let's just look at it easily
okay two hundred thousand pound house if
you want to buy that you're gonna have
to put don't go through the massive mix
that's what we're gonna do in a minute
you don't fine tell me why why why it
doesn't make it sounds like it doesn't
make sense doesn't it
it does yeah and that's why a lot of
people are confused by it because that's
your business but you're gonna be living
there and so I would rather than based
in properties that make more and I would
all have more property so but I can't
answer the question because to me it's
logical so I can't answer the question -
why it's not logical to other people
that aren't a guy clear on it all right
maybe we can clarify that maybe we can
help clarify it to me cuz I to me it's
completely logical that you do not buy
when you live if you're going to invest
in property all right let's have an
argument I'll argue that it's it's it's
nonsense if you can be made no I agree
with you it's nonsense no no I'll be all
had the rubbish argument all right I'll
take the alter the argument that you
should okay so you of course should buy
your own house yes because if you're
where you live of course you should know
yeah yeah you should okay right because
you're going to be living in it now what
what when when around law buys a house
what's the biggest fear
10 inch trash mately yep or nor tenants
or no tenants right if you buy your own
house you know that you're gonna pay the
mortgage off yeah yeah you just yeah and
when you pay that mortgage off you're
buying an asset so why would you why
would you not buy an asset why would you
pay someone else to buy an asset as a
landlord if you own a property the
tenant pays the mortgage off though yeah
so why would you pay for someone else's
house when you could buy your own house
it doesn't make any sense because you
could use the money that you would put
as deposits into multiple income streams
and as long as you're buying the right
house in the right area then you
wouldn't have that problem like okay
there's there's always could have voids
you put we will meet you our Maps put
money aside for voids if I'm living now
I don't but when your side avoids have
contingencies yeah however right people
talk about voids like they're happening
all the time it's a small scale come on
it's not most landlords have proper
tenants most lenders don't our problems
our rents but you only ever hear of the
bad ones cuz so that if you take all
these these TV programs like rogue
landlords and and wrong tenants they're
not gonna tear that they're not gonna
put on a TV program great tenants and
great landlords are they know cuz it
doesn't sell TV but it's a lie great are
great right you is small but you've got
a small amount of voids you've got a
smaller management fee yeah you've got a
small amount of maintenance extra
maintenance of people trashing it but it
adds up compared to you living in there
where there's not everything you have
one house you could buy so you still
want multiple houses and you can buy
more if you didn't if you rented your
nose you know why okay because that sir
I had lots of different apologies why
can't I just lived in one of them
well mortgages on for stocks it was the
battle in which in the top but what but
it would exactly even more point now
because if I'm gonna buy my own house I
have to put down 10% yeah so okay temp
saying so let's just see what's the
average house price in London well
London's about example was London's
burning anywhere Birmingham 300 grand
for a four-bedroom house for three
hundred and yeah so if you get a 90% LTV
for the mortgage you still gonna have to
33 Rhonda so your 30 K down plus fees 36
maybe 38 K but now I'm buying an asset
that's worth 400 grand yes or why don't
you rent because it's going to be about
the same as a mortgage because we've had
this discussion before go into the
calculations a lot well and then you
could buy another use that money you're
going to put as a deposit and buy two
rental properties and then you get in
that income as well but I couldn't buy
to rent apologies for 30 grand
you could not in Birmingham but you
definitely could but then all that well
then why we're talking about why we can
Baron burning and we're somewhere else
we have to money interventive Roselle's
we are like so we don't we talk about
buying properties wherever there's cash
flow good cash flow and so you could
literally put 15 grand or 20 grand away
of our into our sixty seventy thousand
pound house as I hate Gemma or as our
single layer and get good cash worth
month so the deposit money could go into
invest into other areas and then you've
got capital appreciation across all
three now we're granted capital
appreciation might not be as good in
these cheaper areas as it would be in
say farming and I'm gonna get crap
tenants I'm gonna avoid it's maybe maybe
but then if you do all properly and you
do the due diligence correctly and you
get the right management company and you
just do it and treat it as a business
then you limit that you're always gonna
have risk and everything but why a lot
for me in business I'm a both man I'm
not like an and or an or so why would I
not want rental properties and my own
house why would I want to just have
rental properties when I could be making
money on my own house as well you've
brought this point up before the reason
why you ran is because you like
flexibility now four months ago oh by
the way just to be totally clear I
totally don't agree with everything I'm
saying I'm just I just been
argumentative as always and so four
months ago we had no plan oh no maybe
five months ago we were not even
contemplating moving to London and you
just moved into a new house and you were
like a month into its tendency so like
we are now moving to London completely
out of the blue is we've talked about it
a year ago or whatever but it wasn't it
was yeah in the future we'll move to
London and but then five months ago we
said that's it we're moving to London
next month
and then southern so you got the
flexibility you can get out that depends
if you owned that house you would then
have to either move house sale and move
house or you could lend renter out
change your mortgage on it so it the
flexibility that comes as an
entrepreneur in your house
I personally would I would buy my own
home eventually when like when you've
got enough assets that are providing an
income to pay for that so I'm talking
about when you've got more money in the
bank we know what to do with and you've
invested you've got a large investment
portfolio a varied investment portfolio
as well not just necessary property but
different types of property so if you've
got varied portfolio then you'd buy your
house I would do that but not you can
see this is kind of the normal argument
but I don't but I think I believe it's
actually pretty clear-cut okay and I
think that it's renting is clearly
better but we'll go through the figures
I'm gonna have a look it I think it
might be penniless help the fig but the
end of the day written down I massively
people see this dude we've done this
with the apartment I'm I'm living in the
mortgage would be very similar to the
rental figure so you wouldn't yeah so
willful figures in a minute we're over
the figure so let's have a look at the
pro let's have a look at the pros and
cons first so people come because for
example a lot I like your point about
flexibility that is a very very good Pro
yeah however some people that might be a
good thing
some of people they might not care right
would you agree yes I'm II wouldn't but
do you know that the thing is right no
matter what we say people will disagree
with it because they'll have their
version in their opinion something but
that's what this is about is haven't
have your opinion go whatever you feel
but let us look at the numbers and the
logic of it as an investor yeah that's
what we're doing yeah okay so let's have
a look at the pros and cons so I'll try
and hold this I'm still leaning as the
mics so number one you've got
flexibility if you rent now that for me
is quite important yeah because I like
to be able to have them I like to be
able to try different houses I like to
be able to decide what I like I went for
a phase of 111 really
old houses now I live in a modern house
well you can have the variety flexibly
I'm gonna also put variety because it
might not necessarily be about
flexibility but you want that variety
you've got a lot more options if you
rent the weds than if you bought prime
example you were going to look at moving
into cube garden yeah and say you'd move
to Kew Gardens and you realize actually
it's not really if what you wanted you
could have moved then moves again
yeah as you already said that you're
glad you didn't move there you went to
Bacon's because if you were because we
would beckon it's spelt beacon how was
this first advantage right second one
now this is a big one for me gone right
a big one for me when you're buying an
investment property what is your primary
primary purpose of minor investment
property
it bends over and gets tenants as well
what's the end goal angle is it's a good
investment good investment yes it's Nora
wow that's all gold right the total
investment cash will come out whether if
you're buying to live in
watch what what sure what's going on
home you want like right on you're like
given your school schools for the family
whatever yes it's a home isn't
investment so we say that when you
invest buy any property it should be
formulas not feeling ceilings yeah if
you're buying to live it mm-hmm it's
feelings yeah it of course it is because
it because you're emotionally attached
you like the air you like the strip
wondering if when you and Anna went to
look at sort of the house in
Beaconsfield you where any yet you
started walking out there or why did you
not know you don't you go any got all
that's nice I go and I got how close to
the school what school is it clear by
this school what's the street like
what's the garden like what does it look
like from the outside it does it have
big gate I want big gates do not I mean
it's very much picky I did I wanted big
gates
so if your Eagle together so for my ego
just I've always I've always wanted a
house big gate and I've never had I've
never had a happy because my big gates
these big doors as well
he's got me has got big girls got big
girls so but but it's so important that
you kind of get this yeah there's a
property investor because you are buying
with feelings which your own home you're
gonna buy a house that's but probably a
bad return on investment or your body
formulas and you won't be happy with the
house because you're living somewhere
that you don't wanna live you can't have
both no I know who you
I know people that have bought houses as
their homes and then for whatever reason
had to move very quickly separations
divorces work waiver and then they go to
rent that property out and it barely
covers it costs barely I know a family
up and we're used to live that moved to
Australia for work and their rent in
their house at a loss it's costing them
with 150 pound a month because the
mortgage payments and things are and
they can't get enough rent for it and
that was a terrible investment yeah but
they think it's an amazing investment
cause somebody's in there I'm like yeah
you know you're losing like 120 pound a
month away but yeah and then kind of
linked to this but now this is where it
could vary from house to house people
right kind of link to this number one or
a the the houses the nice houses make
bad ROI yeah typically but and now this
this is this is the really kind of the
really important bit people say that
rent is dead money mm-hmm right rent so
is interest interest yes and the
interest on a nice house is normally
about the same
yes I ran theirs so it actually makes
very very little difference apart from
you putting all your money into a crap
into not into a house that you wouldn't
want to live in so for the yeah you
wanna live in so for me for that reason
alone it can't it kind of make sense to
rent where you person live but the only
way of really working it has go through
the figures yeah absolutely that's true
some so let's do some figures so we've
done this before we have however because
people moan because we put 25 percent we
put down 25 percent deposit so we'll say
10 for a first-time buyer okay alright
okay our 10% more Tim cent deposits
actually viable in today's market is
that mortgage lenders doing that for a
first-time first-time buyer would you
think is realistically I think realistic
is more like 15 percent because the okay
you've got all these government
incentives where you can put down 5% but
personally I would always see if the
government's offering you anything don't
take it because there's a hidden agenda
and so all these 5% shared ownership so
I wouldn't even touch my borrowed pool
I'm sure they serve a purpose but I know
many of her I've heard many horror
stories about it so I would say let's
just quickly google it first time first
time buyer so what we're doing this
report house we're gonna use it when you
use that I should start with your house
okay and then we'll and then we'll do it
a cheaper house first time by a mortgage
rate let's just call what Google says
you and we'll use that interest rate mmm
I was will get bill moaning ass okay so
its maximum 90% yeah so I'm saying it's
probably 10 percent is that fairly
accurate I think you can get okay
there's a school ten percent I'm
interested buyer for a long time so it's
a judge look at 10 percent right so your
house how much is it worth the flat
arman that makes seven hundred according
to according to zoo promos price seven
hundred and seventy five thousand seven
seven five
cool so your 10% deposit would be a 7500
so we got an outstanding mortgage an out
of six nine seven five hundred so what
we're talking about for interest payment
well that's just done a very quick
search on Google and for in for
first-time buyers on repayment mortgages
the the comparison rate is 4% so
initially it's like two point nine nine
but then it drops up to four percent so
this to score four percent it's be super
super conservative which makes an annual
payment in interest an annual payment of
twenty seven thousand nine hundred but
that's just purely an interest yeah
that's the interest payments yeah every
year which is what a per month divide
that per a month and that's just over
two one two three to five to three
and this is just this is just off HSBC's
website cool right so so let's say your
apartment if you bought it now obviously
your mortgage payments would be more
you'd also be paying it off yeah well
we're comparing right now is the
interest that you're paying verse verse
the rent right so per month two three
question what's your rent ninth
my rent is four four eight times four
point three three is nineteen or five
right so you're actually making a saving
just on interest of like four hundred
and twenty quid four hundred and twenty
quid yeah a month so weeks rent my rent
is 440 a week so you're saving a load of
money in rent and you're not having to
put down a massive deposit of seventy so
what was your return on investment on
this be it would be okay so if you were
to buy this as an investment property
without it depends what you're gonna
okay so as I'm okay you make a loss yeah
doing is gonna be fantastic
it was gonna make a loss there's nothing
because your your mortgage is gonna mean
nowhere near covered by the red oh yeah
of course you are oh yeah yeah sorry
yeah rent per month yeah yeah your
mortgage making a loss obviously if you
had on our if it was an investment but
we have on a slight little better
interest rate we have three percent so
it'd be slightly bad so you probably you
were you ain't gonna be making much
money at all
and it's interesting because like what
could you do with seventy seven and a
half thousand pound you could buy you
could buy two houses were that easy
three houses sent off it yeah and you
could rent somewhere like this it's not
even like people say this is dead money
but the rent is dead money but it's not
definitely you got to live somewhere
yeah this costs involved in owning a
house isn't it yeah and the thing is
they just just realistic let's think
about how you can invest that seventy
seven grand
right you could buy like I hate jamm
obviously not as a first-time buyer but
as a if you're if you're if you've got a
few houses or whatever you could buy hm
or you could buy a couple of single A's
you could do a couple of buy refurb
refinance deals and pull all your money
out and you could get you could actually
you could create quite a bit of income
from that seventy seven grand if you
knew what you're doing so on a nice
house yeah on a nice house seven hundred
seventy five grand house it is insane to
buy yeah
insane and you only use at the beginning
of the conversation are when I've got I
wouldn't yeah I'm thinking about when
like you get to the point in your life
where you're starting to chill out a
little bit and relax and they because
you've already seen you mom we're never
gonna get there no I know but if people
that do it and you want to buy that nice
house out in the middle of nowhere with
swimming pool I don't know maybe
sometime I've dreams maybe that's our
aspiration I've always wanted to own a
really really nice house okay and that's
just I think I always what doing a
Porsche I call it so a long-term goal
for me is I want to have like a massive
house fair enough even why do you want
to why'd you want to own it that way
he's still your home she's very didn't
point my mindset has been changed over
the last year or two but I've got a
little bit the old mindset a little bit
yeah
let's do it on a more compact like seven
hundred and seventy five thousand pound
is not really a normal house a normal
everyday house for the everyday person
that's watching this so they say well
should we go low end 250 low end so we
start low and we'll just were in the
middle see how it works because the
higher you get the better it is of
course it is yeah so the nice of the
house that the more beneficial is to
rent so let's pick somewhere that say
make 200 grand yeah 200 grand so this
good north of England mean for 200 grand
you can get like a mansion and certain
parts
should we go less yeah I was no hundred
150 actually I would cause 100 there's
to 150 150 so let's say someone's buying
a house just a nice normal house 150
round right so you've got your mortgage
can I say 4% yeah before percent gets
six thousand a year six thousand what am
i doing
yep six thousand a year as that's five
hundred a month five hundred per month
in interest is that interest interest
only yeah that was on HS PCs site yeah
interest yeah well you can't do interest
on the on Reza they know what I'm saying
it that's the end of five hunters the
interest the mortgage would be more yeah
so five in Japan a month now here's the
question
big question what would the rental be on
one hundred and fifty thousand pound
property yeah yeah depending on where it
is but you would see up there year 600
650
there's just 150 house depends how you'd
split it up if it there's single leg
what would you deposit but okay deposit
on our fifteen hundred and fifty
thousand fifteen I think a yeah fifteen
K so did you work that six thousand
pound based on the 155 scrub that's got
that one three five zero point zero four
five thousand four hundred divided by 12
450 450 okay in interest every month yep
so you rental you probably look in
probably about 600 600 650 so you make
me on the final month 600 in rent so
that's your dead money so forth so you
see you're looking at maybe
alright 150 pound a month something like
that yeah you've got to put down 15
grand so in this case I'd be like I kind
of swing both ways
apart from number two for most not
feelings okay why because if you buy
this right so you see equivalent of you
make in about 150 quid a month yeah it's
a view about 150 quid yeah
okay that's that's always got going for
it isn't it really that's all it's got
going for it but what could you do with
at 15 grand what I'm saying you could do
a lot more than that can you
you could make a lot more with 15 grand
if you buy the right investment property
a lot more you can make a lot more than
15 Gordon I know I know investors that
have bought HMOs they up and running hm
although 450 grand not enough 150 grand
but for like 60 can I know somebody that
bought an up and run hit Jamal for like
fifty four thousand pound of no not a
big itch - I'm more of a mall to it so
it's a four-bed hit you more then
Liverpool was like 56k Meeks like it's
not Matt it's not making lords of RAM
but it's making like about just over a
thousand pound a month in rent so he'll
be he's clearing at least 500 a month
profit after all those bills in that and
that's from like a 60 60 Kia but but but
you're gonna be buying something that
you probably don't wanna live in forever
yeah cuz you're not gonna go you're not
know you could eat on the low end house
yeah yeah and you making it's kind of
works at about the same you'd be better
off investing that yeah I'm renting
somewhere you want to live
yeah I must have met because like we all
okay so good first-time home and 150 but
you're not let's face it the reality is
you're everyone wants to progress than
their so what about let's do it for a
like a 300 Grantham well there are 300
grand want it's gonna be in the fact
this this is kind of like things it's
not gonna be double I say it's gonna be
double it's not because just cuz the
house is three hundred thousand pound
doesn't mean the rents gonna be double
no and the right might be maybe 850 yeah
and but the mortgage yeah so I the more
we do numbers the more we talk about
higher than the higher this number goes
the worse it is
now if let's say for example you wanted
to buy a house you wanted to turn into
rooms like HM own you wanted to live in
one of the rooms you a single and you
were younger you didn't care then I'd go
okay fair enough yeah fair enough fact
that because you're buying it with your
formulas and you don't give a crap
you're high if you happen to live in it
and then you're gonna move out and buy
it's gonna go somewhere else in essence
you're almost renting it off yourself
cuz you're buying an investment property
yeah so in that situation yeah it does
it yeah something's got to eat
and he lives in one of the rooms yeah so
fair enough so it depends on your
situation
mhm but personally I think you should be
aspiring to right where you live yeah
you should be renting where you live you
should be using your way to buy
investment properties where investors at
the end of a so IV the money you have
any savings you have sure you should
really be investing that as opposed to
now that people know what's happening
right I know what happened people will
have the argument well your residential
property is a long-term investment cuz
it will go up in capital appreciation
things out so and it'll be many many
people that say well actually I bought a
house and this ten years ago and I've
sold it recently and made like 200 grand
so it is an investment they've made
money out of it what would you answer
would your answer be to that I'd say
yeah great but any property bought would
do the same
hmm so then they would say I would say
to you well and that listen it's your
whole argument or it's not an investment
it doesn't over the water because
because I uh it's not an investment okay
what did you say then I say it's not
good investment okay as I meet him to
meet him mm great well done well done
him but there's there's three levels and
do not confuse me ego so the best is you
buy investment properties that is the
best second best did you buy your own
house and that's good yeah you buy
nothing that's the worst that's the best
case worst case yeah it's the best is
the II buy investment properties they
give you a good ROI something if you're
gonna live in it but at least on the
ladder yeah yeah I can appreciate that
yeah I made a hundred grand well done
him houses all go up yeah well done you
bought it I would I would never say this
to someone by the way who's I'm just
saying I bought my first house I never
go huh idiot you should rent it well
done there yeah they've bought a house
welder if there's anyone I'm watching
this that's gone and bought the houses
and I think it are if I screwed up no
you haven't screwed up because it was a
little bought a house it's still gonna
go up it's still an asset well done for
getting on the ladder well I would see I
would argue that it's an asset it's not
that no no no no I would argue your home
is not an asset and a liability
it's both all right robert kiyosaki says
your home is an out is clearly a
liability it's not an asset well you own
it and it's going up in value yeah this
is this is the argument because yes I
agree with you in one instance it is an
asset in a sense it is going up in value
over time you will make profit but when
you calculate all the costs that you
haven't appear every month interest
utilities also suffer now I know you
will still have utilities with rain talk
about they should see this probably all
the cost to come out that house and then
if you weigh that up over the the actual
profit you making after 10 years is the
profit still look at the interest how
much interest if you add all that
interesting I understand what he's
saying
Robert Kiyosaki is very very clear on
assets and liabilities an asset is
something that puts money in your pocket
every month a liability is something
that takes money so your home takes
money out you so it cannot be defined as
an asset but depends how you look at it
so for example let's say you what we've
done accountant let's listen you've got
a Ferrari yeah and you rented it out for
a hundred pound a month that's put in
pocket in your money every as putting
money about pocket every month but is
that an asset if it's depreciating more
than the hundred pound a month
no it's a key he puts money in your
pocket that's a good argument got
nothing to say that it's a good omen
you've got my oven here look at
appreciation stroke depreciation yeah
and cash flow yeah profit nonprofit now
for me buying your own house over buying
nothing
hmm it is anyway agree with you buying
some ways saying yeah doing some ask
yourself this I think he's saying weird
controversial so it may be maybe we're
done accountant when he's done your
year-end accounts with your home be on
your assets list if your business owned
it if you or no no if you your personal
accounts whatever if you buy have houses
you better say it was nice they would
they would do really I don't think for
one minute there were any profit why I
don't know because I but what I do is my
neighborhood any properties that we buy
goes on our it goes on but they've gone
through a business that's different you
you know your home is it that's your
business investments so when you're if
you're self-employed and you're doing
your year-end accounts would your
personal home be down as an asset or
liability or not even on their so what
so what so what you're saying an asset
is no no and I say I agree I agree at
the assets on this money pocket so I
agree with you it is an asset over time
but there's so many people out there say
it's not an asset because it takes lots
of money at your pocket I get that like
and particularly interest particularly
in this is interest free because
interest free then you should just buy
the cash cash or interest what happen is
it well if you buy it for cash we could
do if you bought a forty grand house
that you lived in for cash is that an
asset interesting
probably yeah because not putting money
back you're not going much it's not
putting money in your back pocket a
month it's still an asset because it's
not whether you rent or own yeah you're
still gonna have utilities you're still
gonna have that so that's the rail
that's a cost but if you buy the house
outright I would argue you could
probably better spend that forty
thousand pounds but it's probably a
better asset and have it on a mortgage I
would say it's cash in the bank an asset
no gives you interest paid put from your
back pocket every move that's it
not point not okay if I'm not point not
not come on it's not that bad
how bad is it not point eight that's a
lot but once your ears man doesn't even
have to start with an or you can get
savings accounts that give you a lot one
office actually interesting we've done a
podcast and there was that M new and
that savings goes like four and a half
percent in remember I was aching at six
on school yeah it may be an American or
point naught naught naught 1 percent but
it's not okay there if you're there then
this is a whole discussion cash in the
bank is actually shrinking is it
actually going up and the true let's get
back to the truth
hey you got some bolts of it is it going
up no it's not weak official argue no of
course it's going up what cash in the
bank yeah not with the true value of the
pound No
so when you take into the true value of
living course under power and it's not
when I'll be shrinking but I do think
it's interesting that we're back will
make you believe it's going up and the
media will meet you believe it's going
up that's why they won't people do
because well why do the bank when you
have money in the bank
listen I'm not saying you should put
them in I think we're I think we're
arguing about definitions here rather
than the principles of it okay so we're
about was an asset was liability look we
both know that put sticky money in the
bank and letting it grow isn't a good
investment no I really it's not we also
both know that the best investment I
hope you guys watching your home because
I rap it's up next I feel like we've
been talking about it for quite a while
but um I think that I think we I think
everyone hopefully should know that the
best thing to buy is investment
properties and not your own home however
if you have bought your own home it's
arguably a liability or an asset it is
going up in value there is Pro I would
never poopoo someone that did that haha
but I would recommend that you rent
where you live and you buy investment
properties that you get yourself
educated they give you are very good
because so like you said before certain
people think they've got a good deal
just as a property yeah it's gonna give
you a good return on investment and then
rent where you live and remember
wherever the hell you want to relieve
and move around and completely agree
with that I completely agree with that
the one thing I will finalize and I'd
leave at the end is when people are
buying the home the buy move with them
feelings yeah so they don't actually
care us and I saw reliably the binary
feelings at that point bombshell is now
time for this
[Music]
because in the news this week an article
on BBC News actually this new website
that's trying to help renters fight
rogue landlords cool it's called marks
out of 10 don't say that's funny
a website that allows renters to write
their past landlords founder Benny arrow
is moving out of his flat when he
received an email saying I'll be glad to
see the back of you he was he had
complained after his then-girlfriend was
forced to throw away hundreds of pounds
worth of clothes when they went moldy
because of a poorly ventilated built-in
wardrobe so the couple felt a little
more groove in the landlord began
quibbling over a missing three pam bed
cover it was then that Ben tried to find
a website where he'd leave a review for
the landlord while there were sites
people could complain about bad bad
landlord Ben felt there wasn't anything
they provided a constructive feedback
and useful information for tenants for
that reason since the website is about
promoting good landlords letting agents
and just as much about good landlords is
about bad landlords hmm so basically
yeah marks a tenancy it's a it's an
online website so I mean I would hate to
end up on there I love the idea of it
love it
but then it's a big buck you're gonna
find lots of people go on there just
because they didn't get the wrong way
with landlords and because landlord
landlords are running the business we
are landlords and we do get some random
requests so one of one of my tenants at
the minute for instance he's lost his
job and he's like eight weeks in arrears
and he's just creating a bit of a
problem at the minute and I'm I can look
at it emotionally and say look I want to
help him out or I can look at it as a
business and say no it's not my problem
you've lost a job you need to pay your
rent because this is a business and we
pay rent so we've instructed and we've
given him a notification to get get this
sorted and if he doesn't if he doesn't
then he's gonna be evicted but no doubt
he'll feel that we shouldn't have victim
and then he could go on that website you
a very one-sided a very one-sided
argument just see you Google in my name
he could give a very one-sided argument
to why he was evicted which as long as
I've got recourse to defend that then
that'll be awesome but so I think it's
great as long as we've got recourse for
landlords to give their version of the
events and yeah but I also think we
should have a website for bad tenants
and for a mark and a tenant out of ten
because let's face it we're all
landlords tenants sometimes can cause
lots of problems tenants can sometimes
be incredibly incredibly unreasonable
and asking landlords so I think it's a
good thing I'm just checking if I'm on
there our stairs not on there what's
that way it's flag let's just come up no
no I think it's really good I think it's
awesome
look ultimately are we're good landlords
we don't have any problems with our
tenants and the sense of we deal with
them quickly but we do our people don't
pay rent now and again and we just deal
with it so maybe we maybe could use it
maybe we could go through and look for
the landlords that get a load of hate on
there and we go we can't at them and go
look man everyone get all them do member
what's his name and the guy we spoke
about the most hated London UK Fergus
Wilson oh yeah if he's on there no he's
not maybe his company maybe in the
company name whatever that is I don't
know but it's I think it's a great idea
but we should have one we should go
contact landlords that I hated and say
look obviously you have a lot of promise
new tenants join do rent tourettes I was
gonna say is if good place for leads in
a good place for until the bad land oh
yeah I think it's funny
but I think it's great I think it's
really good but we need to have one for
tenants so we can as landlords we can
report and we can leave feedback about
our tenants maybe should start one I
think enough time did was I was gonna I
mean Brad far we we recommended Brad
harder art for list a few months ago any
date and he created a list for which he
done so yeah Brad there's a
idea together create a website so we as
landlords we can leave feedback on our
tenant this is called marks our tenants
a reads come with a good name for it for
brats what we're gonna call it marks out
of tenant yeah marks our tenancy out
there amongst our tenants I don't know
but I think it's a banging idea what do
you think I like you I'm just trying to
think of a good eye good name for it but
it could take a while so we'll move on
to this
[Music]
okay so it's now time for your questions
and our answers we we usually find
questions from the Facebook group so if
you're not a part of the group please do
join in its property investors with
Samuel Leeds so first question from
looking at you it looks like you're in a
prison are you in a prison as from Lee
losed of course we are not in a prison
however we've got to get this done
quickly before we get called back for
prom yeah okay cool next was a really
good question just go up go up a minute
view more comments ah that's a good one
that is a good one one question do you
know the answer no I don't but it's a
very good question we can put out there
and maybe somebody can help us with it
so we don't know the answer no but it's
definitely worth addressing it all right
okay so this is the question we're in
the answer parent Lee I'm ready yet we
have our opinions
Johnny Peters one question I didn't ask
at the crash course this weekend what
happens if the mortgage company becomes
bankrupt
does my buy-to-let property disappear
I'm assuming you don't mean my bottle
properties appear so ice and just
they've gotten smoked well they're the
company did the company the more
somebody goes just gone no I'm assuming
he means does the mortgage if the
mortgage lender goes bankrupt what
happens to the mortgage okay I'm
assuming he gets gets transferred onto
another mortgage
yeah so I had a case of this with my
residential mortgage about seven years
ago so the lender went into liquidation
but coventry Building Society bought the
company they always get bailed out so
they got moved over to Coventry Building
Society so that was that didn't affect
me but I was residential so yes you may
be transferred over I mean that's a
question if I were to a mortgage lender
or a broker when you're getting your
next mortgage but you coming back to
your house one day and it just being a
plot of land also laughs than they are
generally no that's not the question
it's like obviously you've got
absolutely no control on like it's like
he's thinking ah if I buy all these
houses through this company and then I
make them go bankrupt so it happened
2008 what happened to mortgage Express
I mean they had mortgages space was a
massive mortgage lender in the battle a
world the the the the brokered thousands
of mortgages name went bankrupt
overnight but them houses still exist
and the mortgages were still getting
paid their would be transferred to
somebody else who buys them out
obviously all the mortgages are
underwritten so I know yeah I wouldn't
worry about it you can't control it and
they'll just get transferred over
someone else right so next selling my
house and I'm joining your Academy is
that see there Johnny please the same
person oh I feel bad taking the mickey
out of him now now when you come on the
academy man we will stop taking the risk
octane we only start taking the Mickey a
game and you join us on the podcast yes
go through the prison one maybe just do
one more this is one feet you here you
go
Victor vas hey guys would you consider
investing in Scotland prices are quite
high over here and properties are
selling super fast often way over the HR
Thanks okay absolutely I'll tell you why
absolutely hold on how many properties
do you own in Scotland zero but so
listen to what you're saying or what you
do listen to us seed yeah no I do and
the reason being just cuz I've not gone
up there and do it the reason it's just
yeah it's just cuz another but anyway I
would do and I'll tell you why I've
bought I bought properties in Scotland
for ambassadors of mine no I like Mexico
lenders all properties have to have a
home rapport before they get listed so
they have to be surveyed did you know
that yes you told me before told you
before and there has to have a bank
approved valuation put in that home
report so you know the valuation of them
before the marketed so it's very very
good for finding below market value
deals because you're in their home
report it gives you a valuation and if
you can very quickly see if you can get
a good deal or not and it gets you can
get access to that their whole [ __ ] and
the home port beforehand so you can go
through an assay so you don't have to
wait for the Soviets coming to however
the laws for buying up that are slightly
different the laws for offering are very
slightly different so that it's not you
get much less ghazan pin up there so do
you know your companies when yeah you
don't get
they're as much because up there your
word is your bond you know our Scottish
people our word is our bond so when we
say we're gonna do something we
generally do it and where's the property
market in English word is our bond when
we saving a lose weight we can't do it
sometimes is that knee but you can put
offers in and you can literally the deep
just but I don't want anymore
you can did you can just pull out and
with very little record what you're
saying is you don't Scottish don't pull
out right okay on that nor which is like
my houses yes we're still talking about
houses so on that no it's good to buy
the Scottsboro for buying investment
properties and did you sell well as well
there's a really good but below market
by there was a lot round Central
Scotland as well with a minute so you
just want to live there invest but don't
rent that know what you can live there
and written there it's beautiful do you
loss scores come on me gang up on this
de liver
I don't lives a move to England you know
that you just asking porch to be
questioned moved to England cuz when I
was young my parents pulled me down here
and he said you gotta come down to
England and I'm like really and I was
brought down kicking and fighting my
freedom right okay let's move on
it's great place to invest alright we'll
do one more question one more okay good
one a good one called on Richards see
this is TC TC Richard see as a
completely owned property stays on the
market til exchange of contracts is any
way to reduce the risk of somebody
putting on a higher offer during the
legal stages yes investing Scotland
yeah a good point Victor I agree with
you that is it's a nightmare anymore
Richard Richard no Richard sorry man I
agree we I do agree I don't like it I
don't like company purchases and
freedom doesn't know what company
purchases what it means it's like
repossessions and if it were the bank
sailing or the Mortgage Lenders of
sailing and what happens with them is
they'll still accept an offer you know
go through legal stages but literally
somebody could come along and offer a
thousand pay more and they're likely to
accept that offer because they want the
highest money they can get for it and
they're not in a rush generally to sell
it so yes a company purchased could take
a litlle k-- three or four fall out of
beds before actually but his question is
is there a way to reduce the risk so I
came up with doing in Scotland which is
obviously a way what's your way and
there isn't a way there isn't a fear
well sure you're when you're doing it
okay when you're putting your offer in
show your commitment and have everything
ready so the legal is is quick like if
they know you're a serious buyer and
you're everything's in place there's a
very little chain or no chain at all
then you're I don't think they look at
it as the case of Luke this person's
gonna offer us off I wasn't prime or I
think me potentially look at it as a
who's in a better position to buy as
well as so it's not just the money it
could be that something might offer more
money but they've got to get a raise a
mortgage whereas you offer a little bit
less money but you're ready to go I know
who I would want to go for but again the
the rules for this are just very up in
the air and they don't
it depends what you're dealing with in
the day if they don't need to sort of
like quickly they might not but all I
would do is be ready be prepared to have
everything in place mortgage in place
cash in place all your documents in
place sure they're whoever sale now that
you're serious and you're ready complete
and just force or completion as quick as
possible so chase them constantly let's
get this completed and just not wait
don't wait for them I know you can just
just be be proactive about it that's
what I would say and on that note it is
time to end we'll be back with next
Saturday at 7 p.m. thanks ever so much
for tuning in and we'll see you soon hey
guys
[Music]
[Applause]